this yeah gonna explain everything all
right we just finished the anime
self-driving car video literally it's
uploading the anime self-driving car
video is uploading right now in order to
celebrate we're gonna play a little game
blind deaf mute nerf prison escape now
just think it's the Year 2084 there's a
major corporation that owns the entire
world and it allows chemical testing on
prisoners that sounds like regular
reality to me now the strange side
effects have left prisoners who cannot
hear who cannot speak who cannot see
they have a rare opportunity for a
prison escape on each team there will be
somebody who cannot speak who cannot
hear and who cannot see this will be the
ultimate test of communication and
teamwork and if these prisoners are
successful they may have a shot they
just may have a shot at the CEO of the
world corporation boys dress up dude I'm
not a boy
subscribe
yeah I have to be the Deaf one with the
sword I want to see okay so I'll be
blind long torso Cruiser but the blind
person will have a riot shield and a
high-powered nerf weapon ideally to be
used as a slow-moving defensive turret
the deaf person is going to have only a
melee weapon
they'll also have sound going through
the Bluetooth headphones thanks son
Heiser to make sure that they cannot
hear and the mute person will have a
nerf blaster here's what the guys don't
know they think that they're just gonna
be able to run around and like do
whatever well actually in this prison
everyone's in the chain gang the prison
name is big n my teammates here this is
medium a and small D now what do you
mean by that Niko was that supposed to
mean what do you think it's supposed to
mean I don't know I can't spell never
dandy sighs his name was Lucifer he
always writes his name lowercase D
that's why they call them small D also
have you seen his dick the first step to
any riot get your click together regain
control of the area team on Team
Deathmatch Oh Billy reach up that's
right here we got to reorganize try
this is I am so scared
all right I'm going deaf all I hear is
death-metal listen Adrienne you have to
execute the commands and push Danny
around game on go go go wait I said we
wait and let him go and then we kill him
on the way out
right right okay
that's okay
taking fun yeah tell me when
what a ridiculous game we're Team WS you
know we're to talk about our patrons
thank you guys for supporting us right
now shout out no we're gonna talk about
a patron you ever got sweat for patreon
we have so we got patrons all day long
they're gonna think right now listen up
we got Remco cats Richard Linder Rory
Jason Imam we got dim key so hotline
Taylor Dunbar Berlin campaign calling
hey I'm so wet for you
baby crying Oh Jake Richard Blackburn
someone for you so wet welcome to the
writers room where we discuss ideas
brainstorm think about the wonders of
what can be in videos and then we make
those ideas into videos well the good
idea is anyway hopefully we're gonna
talk about ideas today first one up on
the board literal smashmouth eye to its
potential I did some research what does
research entail for this video a hair
everyone also knows the lyrics which
means that if you can do something
really fun with it everyone will go oh
man that stupid song that smashmouth
Rose so I wake up every day and I go God
please don't give me a real job the
first thing I thought of was it could be
a mental patient somebody once told me
the world is gonna roll me I ain't the
sharpest tool in the shed
fed to the rules and I hit the ground
Ryan you brain gets smart but your head
gets down like a an old old man on his
deathbed we're counting his life story I
think that could work
like somebody once told me the world was
gonna roll me and then sort of like what
it is about the life of an alien living
on earth so but it was tough told me the
world is gonna row me like his alien
friends are telling him that what goes
to earth don't go there man it's
literally about a tool of screwdriver so
here's a challenge for the literal song
video it's important to find a song that
has back and forth anyway you'd have to
care so it's not just a monologue and
that's tricky like I was looking at
stairway to heaven and stereo heavens
almost impossible if it's not a
monologue nobody's up to a dialogue I'd
also say for the song you generally want
to go with a song where people are
interested in seeing it remixed
reinvented reinterpreted especially this
if so if everybody coyote has an
interpretation and then you can like
give a new one then it's really exciting
if you want to give me like direction
like a three o'clock to shoot at two I
think I can just do this okay all right
we need to stay low we need to move slow
we need to use cover I can't hear you so
okay just nod yeah
just keep that shield in front yeah and
you'll be managed to all go low I give
you have to all go down and then we'll
push down keep the chill in front of you
though okay all right
[Music]
okay this is a good spot stay here for a
second stay low okay okay
Jake come back up you have a dam to give
a damn waiter check I'll pump it you
shoot
okay okay okay okay the whole time that
that was happening I was listening to an
ICP song that doesn't everybody wants to
be a shield boy on this team okay I'll
just take advantage of what we had so
team two wins we're talking about why we
got such a prison in the first place I
downloaded illegal mp3s
Rahil sorry Metallica you know those
those tags on mattresses that say do not
pull the tags off I killed my grandma
most important thing we need to solve in
this meeting as writers our meeting is
that we need to come up with a pitch or
a story for this Chromebook integration
that we're working on a lot of stuff
that we usually do on the corridor
channel doesn't quite fly can't we can't
reference other intellectual properties
so parodies and things like that tend to
go out the window
we have to be careful with violence with
things like guns stuff like that's a lot
of our action ideas to come a little bit
more constrained but on the flip side we
also need to make something that's going
to be big so it's going to have a splash
something that's going to be noteworthy
because you have a big client like
Google behind you
to need to step up your game it's our
job to come up with an original concept
that they can get on board with now the
problem is that if we're gonna do this
as an official sponsorship with Google
we can't do stairway to heaven and not
get the literary rights it's got a
stairway to heaven literary rights calm
I really think the [ __ ] game see
behind your head it's super super funny
I already wrote a whole outline for the
whole video and it's super solid you
just shoot it like commercial here let
me fill you in on my little secret book
it's like top ten games playing your
head by yourself have you ever found
yourself unable to fill your free time
but what's that in social situations or
did you ever have an awkward pause in a
conversation and not know how to fill it
what do you mean in your head how do you
play a game with that boat aboard or
pieces or controllers no it's simple
once you've chosen a game to play and
read its rules in the book all you have
to do is power with your imagination
your best of all each game has been
designed with infinite possibilities in
mind so it'll be sure to keep you
entertained for hours and then we insert
shot like a little booklet being covered
with sand and a sand stone this is a
kind of idea that I can only trust you
to pull off all right well there's some
more ideas the teams appear to be evenly
matched the only way to break a
tiebreaker is to do capture the flag in
this case capture the key whoever wins
it gets to escape to prison and the rest
die ready for that I see feedback on
here we go there it is son one
[Music]
[Applause]
for free we're free men I could second
honey
I can talk again I never see you guys
again
but you know I'll probably start lonely
and I'll maybe suggest that we do this
some more old times sake
wow that was it that was a rough defeat
our communication totally broke down at
the end there I mean cliff had to pull
us by the rope to go in the direction
that we wanted and I was like I was like
why doesn't Renzi I realize it's so
difficult to have to explain everything
because he can't see and you can't speak
it so yeah I'm the only one who's like
we're so wet so fu what so ever you
patreon we're so ever you know cover to
spray like a morning dew so wet are
wetter than I've ever been
are you sure
morning hurry up yeah for these specific
people were wet
please don't publish this video
you